charles i télé c'est petit quelque chose
qui fait que les chiens ne rendait
heureux je salut toi est-ce que je suis
ridicule de faire une fête pour mon
chien
non je suis allé un mariage de chien la
semaine dernière et c'était j'admets
c'était très émouvant
peut-être parce que sont les créatures
les plus adorables au monde rien de sa
petite tête
on dirait qu'il est à la fois furieux
est content parce que c'est on adore mes
chiens je vous aiderai à retrouver votre
chien alors est ce que tu te fous de moi
j'ai recruté absolument magnifique
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas notre chien
vous voyez notre chien il a fait demi
une famille tous les coins que tu as
renifler pendant cette marche est du
pareil au même
kkp sénat les chiens nous ouvrent leur
coeur pour aimer et être aimé et c'est
magnifique on n'est pas encore assez
inquiet ok